the big guy has made up his mind with
his helicopter buzzing so loudly you
could barely understand him Joe Biden
telling reporters how he's finally
decided on a response to the Iran linked
strike that killed three US
soldiers
[Applause]
yes I do hold respon them responsible in
the sense that they're supplying the
weapons to the people who didn't
these attacks in the past what will be
different this time we'll
see C A Wider War C are you I don't
think we need a wider war in the Middle
East that's not what I'm looking for
good answer so what pain could Joe be
planning for Iran a strongly worded
letter a nasty voicemail but one of the
radical mullers in timeout so far Biden
has been moot on the battle plans but
his aditt Administration is giving the
Iranians one heck of a heads up blinkin
is hinting the response would likely
come in stages and be sustained over
time and someone in the Biden Camp gave
the media an advanced copy of the
targets among the pentagon's options
striking Iranian personnel and Syria or
Iraq or Iranian Naval Assets in the Gulf
but whatever Joe decides to do in Iran
he better be careful looks like he's
always already ticked off someone at
MSNBC over the weekend President Biden
said he's ready to take action if
Congress is serious about solving the
Border
issue if that bill were the law today
I'd shut down the border right now and
fix it quickly and Congress needs to get
it done starting
another I guess she said something after
that I didn't quite hear it you know
Dana if there's something you love more
than life itself it's a good solid
interview in front of a helicopter
absolutely I really it's been driving me
crazy for a while and today I snapped
mhm on America's Newsroom yes and then
something happened just before the show
that's going to make me snap again just
kidding I won't bring that up um I will
here's the thing so I I can understand
the White House comms people not wanting
him to take questions on this I can
understand them being concerned about
how he might handle himself at a Podium
however this I think when they come out
and the only time he does ever
interviews with the Press is
when he's in front of the helicopter
when the it's worrying and you have to
use close caption to understand what the
leader of the Free World is trying to
say about wanting to provide a whiter
War about his thoughts and prayers and
feelings about the Fallen US soldiers
and those who are injured here's the
thing you see what that room he just
walked out of if you look at the video
It's called The Diplomatic reception
room set up a Podium there put the Press
pool there as he walks out let him make
a statement direct to the camera because
he's not just speaking to the media he's
speaking to the American people to the
families of the Fallen our troops they
want to know do you have our back
because you have us here in the Middle
East are you going to do all that you
can to protect us if we're going to be
here he speaking to our allies they want
to know what the commander-in-chief is
saying he's speaking to our enemies as
well and I think it makes him look weak
I don't think it's good for him I don't
think it's good for transparency I don't
think it looks good for all the things
that they say that they were going to do
in terms of the most transparent uh
White House in the history of the nation
which is obviously not true and
I I want the leader of the Free World to
come off as strong and doing this in
front of the helicopter every single
time he walks out is just
weak maybe they just don't want people
to hear what he's actually saying that
could be it Jesse you like to have it
both ways
uh it um can we criticize Joe for being
evasive and then hit them for being too
specific that's a good point yeah well I
don't know what he's going to do yet but
I've heard what he's going to do and
he's supposed to hit some proxies in
Syria and Iraq that doesn't do much
because that's the whole point of
proxies they're kind of dispensable you
can retrain young radical Muslims rearm
them and then they're right back on the
battlefield they're like the Joker's
henchmen exactly what I was thinking and
and I heard he's going to hit some
Iranian Naval assets okay so that maybe
cuts off some of the logistic
relationships with the houthis in Yemen
okay I still have to General Waters
still thinks we need to go after the
petroleum industry in that country
that'll set him back years but I think
China is a huge client of Iranian oil so
his Puppet Masters probably don't want
him to do that which is why he won't do
it he's probably going to do as little
as possible just so he can say he's
doing something his entire foreign
policy has been quite a disaster if you
think about the Afghanistan exit you got
a war now in the Middle East you got a
war now in Europe he let the Chinese spy
on us he's losing the Opium War he's
allowing an invasion into Texas this
guy's been an absolute disaster and Joy
Reed should say that because you have to
respect the audience and if I'm all up
for a hot mic me too I love me a hot mic
as long as it's authentic like if they
ever caught you on a hot mic they'd be
like yep that's Greg yeah I got busted I
got busted about the old having to pee
remember right yeah and you constantly
talk about your bladder problems yes
that wasn't me Dana in the bathroom by
the way at Fox when Trump was President
we had hosts here who were very critical
of his foreign policy Venezuela Cuba his
China trade policy his North Korean
diplomacy they were constantly
criticizing mean I think that's good and
that's healthy but don't talk out of
both sides of your mouth cuz that's not
right I think I respect MSM BC's
audience more than MSNBC does you're so
right and you're and you're willing to
sacrifice with going after petroleum
which will drive up the prices in hair
care products I mean I have stock piles
Craig oh good good good judge uh it so
we have these crisis in the Middle East
but it feels like the crisis is in the
confidence of our own president there's
a crisis in confidence going on right
now and there has been for a while Greg
the truth is that the man just does not
project he doesn't project confidence he
doesn't project strength and we all see
it which is why we always have anxiety
every time he comes out whether Dana
can't hear it and I can't hear it
because of the Whirl of the helicopter
or because he like he did last week in
Wisconsin um it it is frightening but
you know what I think that this this
issue is a huge issue and you know I
don't want to go over what we did but
you know what what was it four months
ago when they said that Middle East has
never been more quiet and then today or
yesterday we had blinkin saying it's
never been more dangerous I mean this is
a this is an Administration that doesn't
have a handle on what's going on and I
want to just try to make it clear so
that we don't get political here the
bottom line is they have attacked
us90 times we've got three Americans
killed in Jordan we had the two Navy
Seals and one contractor we have over 80
wounded in Iraq and Syria and 40 wounded
in Jordan so it's 120 wounded six dead
190 attacks on us you know how many
times we responded 10 10 if you're
red-blooded American you're pissed off
you're angry right now all right because
that's not the way it's supposed to be
now the question is no Administration
has gone into Iran okay apparently Jimmy
Carter tried it and that was a disaster
with the with the hostages but you know
if we just go after the houes and this
one and that it's not going to make a
damn bit of difference the truth is that
we either have to drop Bridges or go
after their Munitions or um send some
cruise missiles in there I I don't know
what the answer is but he may have to
get permission from Congress on this and
that's where Congress is going to start
negotiating for Ukraine and for Israel
but the bottom line is um you know when
Trump killed Sol Mani that was the end
of it they didn't respond they knew
Trump was serious there were two service
members who were hit by missile attack
and died was a missile attack but it
were it didn't start a World War if we
go after everyone is saying and what
what uh Biden is said I don't want a
World War I don't want to make a big war
he's such a wuss on the world stage he
signals everything that he's afraid of
Jessica in The Green Room you said
something that was really striking to me
you said the great thing about Trump is
you didn't know whether he was going to
come with a carrot or a stick painted
like a carrot thought that was very
clever always little orange things that
he would carry around
um so there were and we discussed this
yesterday two American Service members
who did die in the wake of the attack I
World War okay but three people died a
few days ago and two people died when
Trump was President those are pretty
cable num talking about we've got 120
people injured since October 17 and you
have 65 service members that died during
the Trump Administration wait a minute
wait
we are in the middle of a war in the
Middle East do not make minimize the
number of Americans being attacked well
then talk about the 65 service members
that died under the Trump
Administration okay so Hezbollah has
announced that they are now suspending
attacks I'm sure that that will be
short-lived but they have released a
statement saying we will continue to
defend our people in Gaza obviously
linking this directly to the conflict
that's going on with Israel in other
ways hopefully that sticks and they'll
be out for at least a little while here
I was heartened to see and I don't
disagree Dana about you know the clarity
that needs to come from the
commander-in-chief in how he presents
whatever he is going to say to the
American public and to the families but
it is good news he called all of the
service members families he will be
there when they are returned to the
United States which is something that
people were wondering about yesterday
and the judge brought up the funding
bill and it is important that since the
end of October there has been a request
from the White House for1 6 billion to
not only fund what's going on in Ukraine
and Israel but to make sure that we can
fight back against Russia and its
proxies which includes Iran and is part
of this so I hope that they will approve
that funding certainly seeing that we
did lose three service members here and
every life absolutely matters I'm just
not for acting as if it was completely
fine that in this period and it's an
abject disaster in this perod never said
that Jessica I never said
I said when we went after the leader
Solan there was not the reaction that it
would start a World War just like all
this guy talks about is we don't want a
wider conflict we got American hostages
we don't even know let me finish we
don't even know if they're still alive
that were taken by Hamas we've got
Americans that were Biden's fault that's
B I'm talking about the danger in the
Middle East to Americans but the danger
in the Middle East to Americans and
indeed to Israelis and to other allies
is rooted in what has gone on in Israel
and actions that all right we got to
move on but we had to point out that
Biden did renew funding to the agency
that helped plan the ATT October 7th and
that was something the funding that uh
Trump had suspended the $6 billion that
didn't the UN un with the UN well then
it's all Joe Biden's fault finally we
agree hi everyone I'm Brian kilme I want
you to do me a favor I want you to click
to subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
page this is the only way that I know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now